is it over well maybe according to the
politicians but of course the most
important verdict is from voters so i'm
really keen actually
to see what our viewers panel made of it
all uh they're weighted they're
politically balanced
so let's have a little look at what they
make of the actions today uh hello
everyone good to see you all now just
before i get to uh talking to you all
individually i'd like to see a bit of a
show of hands
if you think boris johnson should resign
after the publication of that report i
want you to put your hand in the air say
put your hand up if you think boris
johnson should resign
that makes
pretty balanced one two three four five
people who say that they think he should
resign
and if you don't think he should resign
put your hand up now
if you don't think he should resign
three people there who don't think boris
johnson should resign so you can see
actually that's quite reflective
actually it almost i think that in some
ways uh does reflect the uh yougov poll
uh where about three fifths of people uh
said uh they thought he should resign to
a small majority well let's talk to
stella first shall we now stella uh you
uh said that you don't think boris
johnson should resign uh why is that
stellar
no i think
his leadership is disappointing um
because we'd all like to see
men and women of integrity leading the
party and leading the country
um but it's finding some someone to
replace him so i'm not saying that he's
the best person for the job or that he
should be leading the country
but i'm just saying that i i failed to
find anyone who could take his place i
think it's become increasingly difficult
to trust any politicians
and
we begin to trust them and then we find
out they've done something abominable
and we lose our trust in them there you
go so it does feel like my reasoning
that
yeah it does feel perhaps that you're
losing your faith in all of them then uh
stella rather than just borrow us on his
own thank good to talk to you there i
want to go all the way to our youngest
panelist now and that is tom tom horn
now what i'm interested to hear from you
tom is that november 2020 when some of
these parties were taking place you were
at university and you told one of our
researchers that on fridays
you found the police patrolling your
corridors of course in downing street
they were having what's known as wtf
fridays
wine time fridays so a bit different
perhaps from your own university
experience
yeah i think that's what's really made
me so angry about all of this is that we
literally you couldn't leave
your hou you're flat you can you know
people would go down to the supermarket
and come back and be asked what they
were doing why they were
why they were going shopping even if
they'd you know gone out for a bottle of
wine or just
for you know a takeaway for themself
because
none of us were allowed to mix and if
you were you were fined by the
university by the accommodation provider
and sometimes by the police as well and
yeah they did use to patrol the
corridors
and i think maybe
if they'd had that in downing street
then maybe they would have been a bit
more disciplined
uh interesting stuff so tom not a
conservative voter you said that if you
were old enough you devoted green or lib
dems let's talk to rob tyler now because
you are a conservative voter aren't you
rob and what do you make of the uh
report
well
i found it to be a little bit
wishy-washy to be honest there was
nothing new came out and
point three in the conclusions she says
that um
many of the events shouldn't have taken
place which means that she feels that
some of the events were fine to take
place it'd be interesting rather than
seeing the mudslinging to find out which
ones were fine which ones were okay yeah
quite hard to imagine uh really if
you're looking back at which ones would
have been allowed over the under the
rules but um interesting anyway let's
talk to you pradeep now shall we uh
pradeep sakhitaran who is a labor voter
you're based in london um what did you
make of the the report and do you think
the prime minister should resign
yeah i thought the report read like a
diary
of a comprehensive uh set of events but
it's very weak on consequences and
follow-up procedures and guidelines
should be that should be adhered in the
future
it felt like a slap on the wrist or for
the prime minister and a slap in the
face for the british public and i do
feel like the prime minister should
resign because leadership is
about integrity and also setting example
for the national policy and also
international policies we cannot have
our leaders
state that they want to steer world
events and just be hypocritical in
national events so
what does that say about us on an
international stage so pretty pretty
critical there of uh the government well
let's bring in hannah shall we hannah
walker uh you voted labour at the last
election uh hannah
what do you make of partygate
i think we need to go slightly back a
square and remember that parties were
actually not allowed and disguising what
we all know
are parties
as with hindsight as work events
um
i i think is is muddying the waters and
i think to a certain extent we've
forgotten that we know we have intrinsic
values we have a sense of fairness
within us
and we look at those pictures and we
know they were
parties it doesn't matter what you call
them they were parties they were parties
you say it's clear
uh yeah interesting to hear so you're
pretty actually scathing of what was
going on uh there as well and let's
bring in uh dr uh paul blom at this at
this point so it's quite interesting to
hear from different reporters from
different parties but paul you're a
conservative
voter but it feels to me like you might
be losing a bit of faith with boris
johnson would that be
right
yes i i certainly am i mean for me
in the report when it says there was a
lack of judgment and leadership i think
that's very telling
um
and i
reflects badly on boris johnson um and
my concern actually with this whole
affair and i can understand people
getting very bored with it all is that
it's causing damage to our democracy and
our political system and people and
leading to people that's to not engage
with politics which i think is very
wrong and there are lots of principled
um
[Music]
politicians but i think they're getting
very bad press
from that element that's that's causing
uh all the control this controversy yeah
interesting to have
and uh
and i'd be interested to see now with
the two by-elections coming up what
happens to the conservative mps whether
they're gonna be putting in their
letters after the results of the book
could be seeing it could be seeing a bit
of a kicking in those bar election
results let's bring in lisa goddard at
shall we lisa
i know that you know you've had personal
experience of the sacrifices that many
people made
during covid reasons i guess to be angry
towards the passing in at number 10 how
are you feeling
oh lisa i'm sorry i don't think we can
hear you right now i'm gonna try and
come back to you uh
oh
i am here if that's okay oh great you
are keep going sorry about that we lost
you momentarily two things that angered
me today was uh
boris he repeatedly says they're going
to put their arms around people and the
fact that he felt it was appropriate in
his duty to say goodbye i felt it my
duty to say goodbye to my best friend uh
to my
uh uh elderly family
friend that we have she was taken into
hospital she caught covered in hospital
we were not allowed to see her we my mum
got a phone call at two a.m in the
morning to say anne's passed away would
you like to come and see her
i would have liked to have seen her
before i would have liked to have had
time with my best friend before
he can't keep saying put your arms
around people it pains me every time i
hear it
and uh the fact that he just felt it his
duty to say goodbye i just find it
offensive and and today i am angry and
it's not to do with partisan or being
labor supporter i would feel exactly the
same whoever was in the situation
whatever their political allegiance
thank you for sharing your story and i
think it does it is really important to
hear from people like yourself who have
you made those big sacrifices during the
panda make not seeing people that the
closest to them and so we appreciate you
sharing that um let's have a very quick
uh thought uh to end uh shall we uh this
is vic daniels you're a conservative a
supporter you're in london what did you
make of partygate and the report
um just quickly i suppose i should say
that i get why people are angry everyone
as you say has got a story um but i
think if you look at boris in his career
and especially the last five months we
didn't learn anything from the sugar
report we know he likes to drink we know
likes to party we know there are
judgment issues integrity issues and
leadership issues but you have to look
at it as a package he's got a lot of
things right the eu he got he's got
right or he's got us in a position to
get it right the vaccine he got that
right this financial support package he
got a lot of that right and let's face
it he's having a fairly good war so i
think in the round
my own personal view as a conservative
voter as someone who voted for him in
2019 we now have to draw a line on it
and look at the big macro issues that
are going to impact the most of the
population okay thank you very much and
thank you uh for some really strongly
expressed viewpoints today it was really
interesting to hear
everybody's take their